do you think creative darwinism
depends on
pain tolerance
i i
think that's a really interesting
question and i think creative darwinism
there is that there's a couple of
elements too i think there's a risk it's
is it pain tolerance i'm not sure people
will put up with a lot of pain they will
do um if they want something enough they
will tend to put up with a lot of pain
i do think there's a risk tolerance
element in uh creativity which not
everyone has
there is another element which is i mean
obviously taste isn't is a part of this
but sometimes i i see
or listen to work and i just think
this is no good you know
so part of it is
that their some work is better than
others some ideas are better than others
that is just the way it is and i know
that because within myself i throw away
75 percent of my ideas they just die you
know like it like an extinct species
they die and they never come back
so there is a there is a
strong quality element obviously but the
the risk-taking is a big thing and i i
know sometimes people
i can see people
being impressed or interested in what i
do
and
i kind of think part of them would want
to
do that not everyone but some people
think i want to do that i want to do
that but
i've had other people
you know would they want to take the
risk because i know other people very
talented people and they say i don't
know how you can do what you do you
before you've produced something
you let people know about it so that by
the time it comes out so there's a lot
more interest generated about the
project
that is highly risky
because especially if it's a good idea
because a good idea and a good product
is not the same thing you know i have
lots and lots of good ideas
my product varies the quality of my
product varies on you know just how well
i can do implementing the idea so
but once but the good ideas often get
widely publicized especially when
there's a fixed date for the premiere or
the performance and the risk then is i
could fall flat on my face and then the
pain comes in i suppose
um
but i i would put it more it's to do
with for the way i approach things it's
to do with risks and it's funny because
i'm not
much of an entrepreneur you know i'm an
embedded entrepreneur i work at plymouth
university i have a salary so am i
really risky i guess the people
what i would find hard to do
is freelancing now that i think a lot of
people probably who would watch this
there they are actually aiming to go
freelancing
i don't know whether i look up to people
like that or think they're mad because
they are literally in the situation
where if they if their risk fails they
have no money they have they have and
it's it's not just about money either
it's about the self it's defining
ourselves
if i spend two years freelancing on a
project and i fail
it doesn't feel like the project's felt
it feels like i've failed my identity as
a person would feel like it's fun that's
a risk which um
i'm not yet ready to take you know i and
i don't need to because i i love writing
academic papers almost as much as i
love composing and doing films i think
if i spent all my time doing creative
arts i would probably
get a bit sick of it if i spend all my
time doing science i get a bit sick of
it because there's those two parts of my
brain which need filling every so often
but if i don't if i miss out on the
creative stuff for a while that's when i
sit at my desk and think i want to walk
out of this room i can't take it it
almost reminds me of trading in a sense
and almost having a sense of
i don't want to say suicidal because
that's very strong but in some sense
when you pull that trigger and you you
trade and you push that buy button in
some sense there's a you could fail
miserably
and and there's almost an element of
self and
suicide is a very strong word but you
almost have to be willing it seems like
to to risk
a creative death or a death of your
identity in some sense to be
like that does that make sense to you
okay
you're digging in an interesting way
here because yeah it isn't
there's kind of this thing of like if
it's great
if you build it they will come you know
if it's great it'll it'll happen but in
fact there's so many people out there
throwing themselves into the road you
know like
uh
i'll do i'll give anything to make this
work i'll give anything to make this
work if you're not a risk taker
you know i
i think it's it's going to be hard work
for you you know i i
i i think i intuitively knew that and
it's funny you mentioned traders i mean
i did used to work on wall street before
i worked at plymouth university i was a
few years before actually i was a quant
analyst a rocket scientist on wall
street
and i think i liked the element of risk
but i intuitively i'm not
i'm not a trader you know i'm i'm not
really a very good people person i think
traders you have to be able to read
people you have to be very i'm not
uh i'm i'm not great at seeing what's
going on with people and and um
i think uh
i think
therefore my talents lie more in the
creative
therefore if i'm going to press a button
on that trade
and risk that you know the trader would
be risking whatever you know five
million if i'm going to press the button
and risk my reputation and my future
career it's going to be on the thing
that i know how to do business with or
that i'm best at and
it seems that events have conspired to
teach me that this is what i'm best at
this is you know that i'm uniquely not
uniquely but um well positioned to be
good at and therefore that's where i'll
take the risk i think that helps once
you know you've got a unique
product once i know i'm willing to throw
myself
into the road that's a bad you know
metaphor but i'm willing to to stick my
neck out because this is the best of me
and if i'm gonna fail with the best of
me then
then i failed but that's all right but i
haven't
i haven't yet had a big fail
do you know the good news is is that
i know that if i do have a big fail and
i
if this was just after a big fail i'll
be saying different thing but i know if
i do have a big fail
i it will help define my future for me
you know it rather than destroying me
uh it would help me to
you know having to deal with a big
failure i'm sure would have an impact on
me in a positive way i think until
you've
i'm theorizing here but you read about
it that's what it is i read about i hear
about it all the time you know the
entrepreneurs they have failed
businesses i haven't had really a failed
business yet if you know what i mean
so i'm confident that if that did happen
um it would just teach me more and i
just have to move on and um
you know you so in other words the
payoff can be so great if i take the
risk
and the failure if the risk doesn't come
off
is not so bad you know no one's going to
kill me i'm not going to throw myself
off a bridge you know i'm going to i'm
going to pick myself up i'm going to get
back to doing my job i'm going to go
through a period of pain
but i'm going to learn and i'm going to
be a stronger person and hopefully a
better artist afterwards
you